when you think about a professional
cheerleader your mind instantly goes to
big hair red lips blue t-shirts in the
crop top it's deemed as female you never
think of a man doing them so wanna step
it up and break the boundary for us
there's a thrill and a confidence that
comes out my name is Quintin Barone and
I'm Napoleon Jenice and we're our job as
cheerleaders is to engage the crowd we
are right alongside the women hitting
every shot say every period every jeté
everything we do together our
relationship with our teammates is kind
of amazing and being integrated into the
team was super fun it's like the
families you never know you needed
[Music]
the audition process is open to everyone
men and women in the past men have
registered but we were the first to to
register and show up we actually knew
each other before the audition we
competed at rival colleges we were both
the only guys on our dance team and then
we ends up being both with obscene
audition where no other guy has tried
this that felt like okay I'm not just
dancing for me we make this this is huge
I was ready I was hungry I was eager and
being announced as a member of the team
I was so excited
everyone's like congratulations you've
made history you've made history why
were just like yes make the team so
excited the fact that now we are
considered ambassadors for not just
dancing in general but now for the LGBT
community and people are reaching out to
us it's cool to be able to connect this
one equal in that level let's just do it
one time walking through not only where
were the first two mills in the NFL but
we were the first team ever to go to the
Super Bowl just as a cheerleader
standpoint that doesn't happen for 90%
of the people that come into this
industry so our first year was pretty
monumental good job you guys
[Applause]
we had a 10-month season I was never
expecting any of this to travel to get
messages from friends and family saying
that we're changing their kids lives
we're encouraging them to do anything
that they want and even across the
country guys all over now the Patriots
have a couple Eagles have won Saints
have a couple more Seahawks have a
couple a half the squad is co-ed so it's
pretty cool to see that something that
we did on a whim and just because we
went to dance with her friends open the
door for so many guys to step into their
purpose
you
[Music]